as we enter the flu season public health
experts are warning about a so-called
twin endemic of the flu and covid19 now
many people are wondering
how to tell if their cough is just a
cold or
copin 19. cbs news medical contributor
dr david against joins us now
with some answers to these questions dr
aegis good morning so how do you do it
you've got
a cold you've got the flu and then
you've got the coronavirus
there are some similarities but there
are a lot of important differences can
you welcome
us through them um sure tony so
they're all viruses right coronavirus
causes the common cold
coven 19 obviously and then influenza
amb
caused the flu and the body's immune
response to viruses
causes you to have fever chills causes
you to potentially have diarrhea
headache and so they're the immune
response to the virus the body doesn't
care which virus it is a virus is a
virus so the similar the symptoms
are remarkably similar what's unique to
kovid
is the change in taste and smell that
happens in some people
but but not all but the symptoms are
really overlapping so it's gonna cause
issue
as we get into the season so then what
guidance would you give people about
precisely when
they should go to their doctor or at
least call their doctor
so what these viruses do is they go into
your lung
and they cause inflammation the lungs
can get leaky and can make it difficult
to breathe and that's what we worry
about that's why people need to go to
the doctor or the hospital when they
have difficulty breathing
and that classically means there's too
much inflammation in the lung and at
that point
the doctor will do a rapid test and they
can know whether the patient has flu
whether the patient has coven 19 or
something else like the common cold
and make a decision whether that patient
needs oxygen or hospitalization or can
be monitored at home
the other is you can have a pulse ox at
home and you can actually measure your
own oxygen
and so if it starts to dip below 94
percent
then it's time to call your doctor and
what is your biggest concern
as we enter a period where we're going
to have the flu and the coronavirus side
by side
what worries you as you look at what
could happen to the country
well you know in many parts of the
country now where there's spikes in
cases the hospitals are starting to be
full the icus are full you couple that
with the flu
and you have a double whammy there which
really emphasizes the need for flu
vaccination
you know you can die treat the flu by i
mean prevent the flu with a vaccine in
many cases and that
is critical the other key is diagnosis
remember if you diagnose the flu early
through a test
you can take a drug a tamiflu or one of
the other anti-flu drugs or give it to
your family members
before they're symptomatic and they
won't get sick
so it's really important that we keep
testing going in the country
all right so pay attention